speaking of people i don't like i don't
even know of this person but i don't
like her this tiffany cross on msnbc
i've never heard of her until this
morning i saw this clip um i don't know
is she does she host a regular show or
she was a guest host is it a regular
show i'm not even sure
but she went on a highly racist rant
this morning
completely racist rant so i'm gonna play
her racist rant and i want you to think
as you're watching this rant have you
ever heard anything this racist
on on fox news because i'm guessing you
haven't here we go
okay carlos watson sade steel
van jones what do these three folks have
in common well they're all people who
have been prompted up by wealthy or
powerful white americans and yet we the
keepers of the culture don't really rock
with any of them like that now obviously
the three of these folks are most
definitely black faces however they are
not necessarily black voices and there's
a difference let me explain take a
listen to these half-witted self-hating
remarks from state still
barack obama chose black and he's
biracial i'm like well congratulations
to the president that's his thing i
think that's fascinating considering
considering
his black dad was nowhere to be found
but his white mom and grandma raised him
but hey you do you
what
so that is undoubtedly a black face
whether or not she knows it but it is
most definitely not a black voice yet
i'm sure someone is giving themselves a
big diversity pat on the back
by having that modern day menstrual show
saved step and fetch it on the airwaves
spewing her continued nonsense now let's
listen to jeff bezos's black friend van
jones after a donald trump speech
he became president of the united states
in that moment
okay
now let's be clear van and carlos are
far from being sage but there's
certainly something to be said about
wealthy and powerful white people
elevating certain voices over others
all right people
i put on my very smart news anchor fake
glasses i don't wear glasses these are
not prescription they're just fake
glasses which is what these clowns are
wearing all the time but now i look a
little smarter i sound like someone who
knows what he's talking about right that
woman everything she just said right
there was racist to clear it up i said i
wasn't sure if she's a guest hose or has
a show she has a weekend show she took
joy reid's weekend slot when they
upgraded joy reed to the weekday over
there okay nobody cares about the msnbc
programming i mean nobody's watching it
nobody cares but every now and again we
got to cover this this lunacy because
for the 10 people that do watch i want
to help these people you know but she's
a racist that woman she is a racist she
looks at black people sage steel van
jones etc and she sees black people who
don't behave how she wishes they behave
and she's basically saying they're not
black her line they're black faces but
they're not black voices well she also
called sage uh sage steel self-hating
everything sage steel said there was
perfectly fine you know she made a true
commentary on barack obama sage steele
by the way no one hated sage steel until
last week she's been an espn reporter
for probably 15 years or so nobody hated
her until last week then last week she
just said that she didn't want espn uh
forcing people to be vaccinated that you
should make choices for yourself you
know talk to your doctor my body my
choice kind of stuff now she's a
right-wing maniac funded by white people
as this lunatic says van jones by the
way also is a liberal he is a liberal
he's too liberal for me at this point
right he's like sort of just like a bill
maher style liberal
who occasionally reaches out to the
other side right uh he's he's had talks
with candace owens he sometimes reaches
out to people on the right i'd be happy
to talk to him by the way um
but if
imagine if a host on fox news
did what she just did there here are
black people who are sellouts thus are
not black which by the way this is what
here wait i'll i'll do it with my
glasses to make a real point
this is what
the lefty media does with all minorities
they treat them like pets okay this is
what they do you may remember when peter
thiel came out of the closet years ago
an out magazine which is a big
lgbtqlmnop
magazine said that he's not gay sure he
has sex with dudes but he's not gay
because being gay is about a political
ideology not simply your sexual
preference so they will take away your
sexuality just like this woman just took
away the skin color of van jones and
sage steel these are not good people
i don't like them very much
i don't like their ideas and i don't
know why they're on television and by
the way when she's talking about wealthy
white people that give these people
money and put them on tv
uh does she know she's on tv does she
know that uh msnbc is a big corporate
conglomerate that
he doesn't know connor has no freaking
idea if she knows that we don't know we
don't know